hey Doug Walker here I just a horror
movie this weekend not the mummy like
many of you didn't see but I've been
hearing a lot of good buzz about this
movie cold it comes at night and you
know reviews are really good it's like
an 86% of Rotten Tomatoes and a lot of
people I know I saw I didn't liked it
when I saw one review by by Jojo Vargas
that I didn't watch it yet but just on
the description just said you know save
your money
don't go see a complete ways to die oh
my god
and the race a little question mark over
my head because this is being like
really really good reviews so I but I'm
interested in new horror films I like it
while horror film is done really well
because it's very hard to scare me and I
think it's very interesting
um I don't know it's kind of like good
comedy it's all susceptible so I love
the different styles and everything uh
so we got this movie and one of the
reasons I'm doing this because I had
this pricing could be a huge hit or
anything but I just want other people's
feedback on this because there's just
something about movies that have the
word it in the title horror movies about
a you know that I just can't get into I
couldn't get into it I couldn't get into
it follows and I couldn't get into this
and I'm really wondering if I'm missing
something on this one and I won't go
into spoilers yet you know give you a
brief description of it and what I saw
and everything and then those sort of
it's hard to talk about the pros and the
cons of it without going into spoilers
but but here's the spoiler free version
first pretty much it um it looks like
our time our world are not the
not-too-distant future
and the family lives middle of nowhere
some sort of terrible disease has taken
over and you know people are dying it's
just walking dead without the walking
dead just saying it right here that's a
rickety office
which is one of the problems but that
gives you an idea that there's something
where if you breathe this or whatever
yeah go blank you get all this crap on
you and you die or your organs spill out
you know or something you know it's not
even entirely clear what it does look
like you died and they got to burn the
body that's a very a far far away you go
where gas mass all the time and stuff so
family comes across this person or this
person comes across them I should say
breaks into the house don't know if it's
a friend or a foe uh I should probably
stop there the more I think about it
because part of the movie is I think
kind of the suspense and the surprise
and then who do you trust and stuff like
that's all stopped there and that's very
early on in the movie but it's kind of
what you think it's going to be in a
walking dead without walking dead movie
you know it is a survival piece and who
do you trust who's the real monster you
know that kind of stuff stuff you kind
of expect uh and it's all I got I got
exactly what I would expect out of this
except I'll be honest I was expecting a
few surprises I was expecting you know a
few more creepy scenes out of it and
then I 10 I got the pretty much what
Mozambique movies are with the people
fighting among each other and trying to
figure out you know should I trust this
person should I not should I kill this
person should I not friend or foe uh
except there's no real zombies in it
there there's some bad dreams uh that
can be a little creepy uh and and good
acting and good pacing and stuff like
that but uh but this didn't really grab
me that much because even the characters
are not bad and the actors are not bad
but it's not really told in a way that's
like maybe because there are no real
super surprises in it I mean I know I'm
not saying much and that's one of the
reasons of nothing that much because
it's like okay well what few there are I
should you know leave that but uh it
just kind of seems like you're watching
these be
well you know try to get along and then
should we get along and then you know
things of course fall apart I mean you
can kind of tell them pretty early on
and and then that's it it just kinda
stops um and like I said I kind of
because those movies getting really good
reviews I haven't really read any of the
reviews
uh I'm curious what other people's a
feedback is because there are a couple
people in the theater and like nobody
was booing or anything like that but
what ended they're just like okay I
didn't even know what to think
uh and I'm trying to think you know
there's a movie Cole I think was called
buried and you priory this is a film of
a guy that there's buried underground
and it's all told from that point of
view just into the box and I was
thinking why do I like that more than
this because it's when you get the N
it's kind of a similar idea and I read
there's a little bit it felt like
there's a little bit more commentary
with that ideas a little bit more of a
unique twist you know just having it in
the box and everything but you still got
this idea of the world outside you know
with him making these calls and there's
good commentary unlike the media there's
good commentary I'm like you know
business and businesses and such and
political and everything like trying to
distance themselves from him you know as
far the terrorist side and plus just the
simplicity of him there's a snake
delegates in the box and everything and
it was trying to fight off the snake and
everything is will people get there in
time and I felt like that was such an
interesting new kind of idea but it
really is just another survival quick
and I'm thinking this is a survival
quick to and just telling nothing really
that new was added if anything it felt
like a lot was taken away and the only
thing I can figure is that maybe the
idea is that by taking those elements
away kind of like you know the zombies
and the chase you know and stuff like
that you know and only focusing on the
people maybe it's just somebody wanted
to see a film where it's like oh I
really want to film about the people
that's not about the zombies even though
those films are really
about the people it's never about the
zombies uh so I feel like that's already
being done it's just now we know the
zombies so it's the only other thing I
can figure is that because there's two
interesting things happening in this
movie uh when I was watching it one is
that everything is kind of has this
impending doom about it and again
without giving too much away I mean that
a lot of movies have that but this one
especially can't have this impending
doom aspect so maybe that's kind of the
idea it's just watching you know people
sort of in this inevitable situation and
what they do maybe but I just feel like
that's not that interesting or not it's
not not interesting as it could be uh
and maybe that's because like even the
people I didn't know a ton about them
before this all happened I mean if there
was a contrast you know maybe we could
see what they were like beforehand you
know even like you know issues like loss
and even Walking Dead or like orange is
the new black and all these are uh shows
they show their lives beforehand they'll
cut back because that creates such a big
contrast it's like wow how do we get to
this point and that wasn't really here
they talk a hint about it but but not
that much so I never really even though
these actors are good I never really
felt like I really got to know these
people you know the father a little bit
maybe because he's a Yeller he's a
screamer he's a super paranoid everyone
else I'm kind of thinking like even
they're just kind of generic people um
and they're acting very well but I don't
I could look at the mother and be like
okay let me tell you all about her I
couldn't do it I couldn't look at the
son and be like let me tell you all
about him he likes his dog okay I know
that uh but yeah so that's that's kind
of a thing with this movie so even from
that angle of just watching something
really just bad happen uh you know and
human nature in human condition the
human animal and everything isn't that
interesting because I didn't find them
super interesting and the other thing I
was going to say the second interesting
thing is that maybe this was just my
screening but the okay so this is
wide-angle that you're looking at right
now and depending on the framing in a
movie and the framing of the screen and
everything it either fills with full
screen or you get these two black bars
on top you know that depending on the
way it's shot well the movie starts out
the entirely filled like this like your
screen is right now but then if it keeps
going these black bars like in one cut
will suddenly be like a little video
sort of like these black bars there okay
that's interesting and then after
another cut they'll be a little closer
throughout the movie okay and then near
the end it's like this much is like this
much black bar in there and again the
only thing I could draw from that is
just impending doom things be more
claustrophobic I guess uh I just incited
that interesting um so so okay so that's
the spoiler free version uh is it a
bottom line I couldn't get into a
nothing as bad messing its off on saying
I really couldn't get into it I didn't
entirely see the point I felt like it
was one of these survival films with the
a good chunk of the exciting element
taken out no real twists and turns and
then all the other exciting stuff we've
seen a million times so so so that's
that's my initial thought and I love to
know what you think you know if you go
and see it okay now the spoiler
territory pretty much this thing this
disease or whatever it infects the
little little boy in there there's a boy
there's a little boy and a little boy
touches the the bigger boy you know it
cuz he's like walking around or
something we even know he played cuz
he's sleepwalking oh no so that's never
revealed and there's also these two guys
that try to jump them later we never
find out who they are and yeah so
eventually you figure out the little boy
is infected and the boy is infected and
everyone's in the same room so they're
all going to be infected I mean we can't
know this but they decide to split apart
and even the boy the teenage son is like
do you'll get it if he's got
and I got it too but they're like no no
we gotta throw them out and we gotta
kill them and we got a yada yada yada
and it's like but it's already too late
why not have why not everybody band
together and just be like you know what
let's just enjoy these last few moments
these last few days because we know
we're all gonna die but no they didn't
get this big fight they're trying to
shoot each other and they're not really
talking in fact one family's gonna leave
it's like just let him leave and they're
like no they might come back and see our
food is good but it's like they're
already dead uh and everyone those are
going to die but they have this big
thing where they're shooting each other
and like that kid gets shot and on the
wife get a super dramatic and super
savage and everything but it's like you
Yury know they're all dead
and maybe that's supposed to be the
commentary it's like even if you know
you're gonna die I mean you do
everything you can to hold on and you
get delusional maybe maybe that's the
idea I'm not sure but that was the
biggest thing that was bothering me
because I'm trying to watch the thinking
is there any way that they that they all
could not be infected and at the end
it's pretty much saying no no that they
all have to be in fact because they all
took off the map at some point they're
all in the same room at some point uh
and some things aren't answered which I
thought maybe was supposed to be open
like you never see if the boys face is
actually you know turning into a thing
or his eyes going black and the fire but
keep your eyes closed keep your eyes
closed okay so it's indicating he has it
but then it's like hey take that mask
off nobody took here okay so he thinks
he doesn't have it but then later the
teenage boy starts vomiting up and he
gets the stuff and he dies it's tough so
it's like okay well they did have it
then so even for that open option that
did they have it or did they not it's
like no they have it like even that's
answered so you can't even have kind of
akin us in there of trying to discover
so so yeah they're sort of and I'm just
waiting for like some sort of monsters
or something to come in because the
advertisement keeps this kind of vague
and it
does it's just a disease um you know
it's 28 days later just you know except
when you get the disease you just die
apparently or maybe your guts explodes
the dogs got to explode at some point um
and I just don't find that very
interesting uh I find that it was sort
of with these supernatural stories of a
disease or something that turned into a
monster or whatever
yet the commentary comes from what
happens in this situation you know but
it's still coming from this exciting
situation it's a new twist on it
you know when they created zombies or
they create these monsters or these
disease even 28 days later you know sort
of these fast running people it's not
technically zombies like it's Thomas
but you know it's these people that can
run very fast you get a drop of the
blood and that's it and stop and say how
do you react to that so so if all these
other movies didn't exist
I'd say this is brilliant I say this is
a wonderful brilliant analysis of you
know the human animal what they do in a
life-or-death situation when
everything's kind of closing in on and
stuff but it's like have you seen this a
million times then with more interesting
scenarios so I I just couldn't get into
it I couldn't follow why this was
interesting uh and it's not done
horrible uh and clearly a lot of other
people are getting something out of it
that I'm not getting so I would love to
know that the people that saw it and
really liked it what you got out of it
that I'm missing uh you know everyone
just I've been you discreet and you suck
like many YouTube comments do great go
ahead uh but I really like to know like
outside of what I said the people that
like this movie and how did it make a
connection with you well what did it do
that really grabbed you because this is
doing very well Rotten Tomatoes and it's
not a poorly made film you know I mean
it's got good atmosphere a shot well the
acting is good but I mean I did not get
what was so special about it or what was
new about it I didn't see in a ton of
other films like this so um yeah I love
to know what you think again just uh
some about movies with the word
in it - it follows I have the same
reaction I was just like okay I was
interested what was going to go on but
does that I'm period isn't that Wow
I guess I hope if there's all these
things or it's like well wasn't about
that okay well what was it about and
nobody ever tells me the answer or even
feels like you know kind of like a racer
head or these David Lynch bills and
stuff where it's like I can't tell you
what that's about you know but there's
something so uniquely strange and still
engaging that sucks me in but at the
same time I can see how someone you know
they wouldn't like it
you know punch-drunk love you know a lot
of Paul Anderson movies that you know
like the guys that did Boogie Nights and
stuff I really like his movies even
though I couldn't explain it through a
good chunk of them what they're about or
why they exist by find them intriguing
and they like screen savers going on you
know and I find them really interesting
and engaging and the people interesting
and and I don't know where it's going to
go we're with this one as soon as it
starts if you ask me where do you think
it's going to go I would say where every
movie like this goes I'd be writing
except they would take out the you know
the threat of zombie you know the
monster or whatever so that's like oh
it's even less than what I thought so uh
so yeah definitely let me know and to me
the sin seemed unique enough to really
garnet that much attention but but maybe
you're seeing something I'm not seeing
and I actually would really like to know
what people who enjoy this film enjoyed
about it so if you thought you liked it
leave in the comments below I definitely
like to hear your opinions on it and why
you got into it you don't really need to
explain if you can get it I mean I
understand but yeah I like to know I
like to actually hear your thoughts on
it so um yeah that's about it and
there's more stuff coming soon
you